[Musique]
ils ont fait le show sur la scène du
complexe sportif collègue pablo neruda
aux mureaux une cinquantaine de bboy et
big girl se sont affrontés samedi 2
avril une battle étape inter région ile
de france normandie de break dance et
est organisée par la fédération
française de danse et la communauté
urbaine gps et oh ça fait du bien de se
retrouver on va dire depuis cowitz a
repris doucement les événements et là on
voit vraiment une bonne dynamique ça
s'enchaîne bien sûr les week-ends et
surtout les qualifications dans chaque
région donc chacun se prépare un peu
dans ces régions on retrouve en fait là
dans notre région un peu les personnes
avec qui on a un peu l'habitude de
s'entraîner au qu'on croise succès ile
de france normandie mais a
principalement on va dire beaucoup de
gens d'île de france du coup c'est cool
c'est un bon bah tel pour se remettre
dans l'est en jambes en fait c'est pas
seulement la compétition n'est
oui les partages la communauté
hellénique
pour moi c'est ça me serve avec ce type
de sélection aussi ça permet de
découvrir de nouveaux talents qu'on
n'aurait pas forcément l'occasion de
voir ailleurs et aujourd'hui on peut
vraiment parler de statut de haut niveau
de breaker 2 et breake de haut niveau et
cette étape est qualificatif pour la
finale du championnat de france de
breaking qui aura lieu le 12 juin à
bordeaux ignorons fils de breakdance
dans les yvelines on n'a surtout pas des
lieux équipés et il ya une vraie volonté
politique
que ce soit au niveau municipal et
communautaire ben d'accueillir cette
discipline le public a pu assister aux
finales et demi finale c'était bien j'ai
bien aimé s'étaient précipités agréable
à regarder aussi tu es trop bien et dans
ces super bien
c'était
prochain rendez vous une battle
international en octobre aux morts